[Music]
yeah
in this film we wanted to kind of strip
it back and wanted have more fun with it
you know I'm tyka had the exact same
idea and we were both saying in Thor
Ragnarok let's try and have more
attitude
Greg rocks a new cycle from the light of
the world all the realms of the universe
it's the destruction of the old' and the
rebirth of the new Nets really exciting
to me surprise this will be such fun the
way that I've approached this is to
rebuild it in a new way look great dude
I think it's just perfect mix for where
the character and story need to go you
know different costumes different
weapons different cast or characters to
work or give you a different energy Thor
has been a crisis he never went back to
Asgard to claim the throne he wanted
adventure when we pick him up he's at
the end of this search for himself when
the ones we serve on this trip I'd say
the odds are about a half a million to
fund
[Music]
you know I want this to take people on a
ride and and inject some comedy into it
an adventure that keeps people laughing
along the way but also has inspector
call them stuff that it gets people so
he's a fighter
so much has happened since I last saw
you I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh and then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
[Music]
Morrow you have no idea how loved the
goddess of death is invaded as God
oh I miss this
and you know how to fight loose me did I
word now I want easily this in sound
right uh that's true
as god is dead we'll be reborn in my
image i thoughtyou Bixler to see me near
the stopper here now to prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
[Music]
surprise this be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
by the same unit I'm just a couple of
hotheaded fools yes
I'll collect fire door like water kind
of like fire butthole like raging fire
so I like smoldering fire
[Music]